newspaper in texas the austin american
statesman
said on saturday that it will not
publish the description
that local law enforcement gave them of
a man
suspected of shooting 13 people
a guy shows up shoots 13 people on
friday night
and the newspaper will not publish the
description of that
suspect because it could quote could be
harmful in perpetrating stereotypes
which now i think everyone has an image
of what this person is but you're not
allowed to say it
editor's note police have only released
a vague description of the suspect
shooter
as of saturday morning the austin
american statesman
is not including the description as it
is too vague at this time
to be useful in identifying the shooter
and such publication could be harmful
and perpetrating
perpetuating stereotypes if more
detailed information is released we'll
update our reporting
so what does the suspect look like well
according to the austin police
department he's a black male with
dreadlocks wearing a black shirt and a
skinny build
so he's a black guy so they won't
publish it if he were a white guy they
would have published it
remember when george zimmerman and
trayvon martin
got into got into an altercation it
wasn't even just that it was
completely use of force on the side of
zimmerman and trayvon martin was not
using force at all you saw there were
lots of injuries on on zimmerman too
but because in that case and this was
years ago because they
initially thought zimmerman was a white
guy they published it a white man
hunting down a black teenager
and they pretended that he trayvon
martin was like six years old and
remember they posted that very young
photo of him
and then the narrative fell apart
because zimmerman's not a white guy he's
a hispanic guy
and then they tried they redefined it
and the times they said he's a white
hispanic as they were doing anything
they could
to grab onto their racial narrative
namely
the one that lebron james for example
advances that black men can't leave
their homes without being hunted down
by racist whites in this story
that doesn't work that the narrative
falls apart in the face of these facts
and so the newspaper says no we can't do
that because that would advance
harmful stereotypes
this shows you a racial double standard
that is uh when the facts contradict it
there are no consequences
hey hold on i know i know that you're in
a hurry to go pre-order my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which will be on pre-order for
another
eight days or so and then it's gonna be
released on june 22nd you can get an
autographed first edition copy right now
i know you're in a rush
but first just ring that bell subscribe
like this video
head on over subscribe to the michael
null show audio podcast wherever you get
your podcasts
then you will never miss any of our
content all right you can go get the
[Music]
book
[Music]
you